[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
avec nos deux invités du jour pour soi
gabriel cluzel vous êtes journaliste
rédactrice en chef du site boulevard
voltaire est également chroniqueur à ses
news
on vous voit de plus en plus ailleurs
j'ai l'impression selon ton se réjouit
vous êtes aussi essayiste et votre
dernier livre enraciné nous sommes tous
d héritier a été publiée aux éditions
arte geie on va voir sûrement la
couverture de votre livre eh bien la
voilà il a qu'à demander merci beaucoup
à la régie smadja l'oci bonsoir il vous
êtes le directeur de cabinet du maire de
nanterre vous avez été parmi vos
expériences le chef de cabinet puis le
conseiller spécial de marie george
buffet qui était la ministre communiste
de la jeunesse et des sports
entre 1997 et 2002 et nous commençons si
vous le voulez bien
cette émission par des annonces faites
par valérie pécresse vous n'ignorez pas
que valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région ile de france
est candidate pour un nouveau mandat le
scrutin aura lieu à la fin du mois hier
soir sur le site du figaro carl meeus
dévoilait les propositions de valérie
pécresse en matière de sécurité
la présidente de la région se féliciter
d'avoir déjà déployé des caméras de
vidéo protection sur le réseau de
transports publics d'île de france vous
savez que c'est la région qui a la
tutelle sur ces réseaux de transport
qu'il s'agisse de la ratp ou des rer
elle voudrait maintenant connectés
toutes ces caméras pour pouvoir les
utiliser
grâce à l'intelligence artificielle on
va détailler tout ça mais d'abord on
écoute valérie pécresse
elle était ce matin sur france info j'ai
assumé de déployer 80 mille caméras de
vidéoprotection et dans six mois
ces caméras elles seront reliées dans un
centre de commandement unique de la
police des transports
ces quatre-vingt mille caméras elles ne
sont elles ne sont vraiment utiles que
si on peut avoir une usager de
l'intelligence artificielle pouvoir
faire des vidéos patrouille donc on a
besoin de cette intelligence
artificielle on a besoin pour ça de
faire évoluer la loi qui aujourd'hui
le permet pas je demande un débat
national avec un venu vraie consultation
sur les aspects éthiques
alors contrairement concrètement pardon
comment ça se passe évidemment il peut
pas y avoir un agent qui surveille ses
80 mille caméras qui sont déployés donc
dans le réseau ferré dans le métro dans
les bus mais ce système est extrêmement
utile pour élucider des délits valérie
pécresse explique ainsi que
l'élucidation des délits s'est amélioré
de 20 à 30% grâce à ses caméras en gros
quand il y a eu une agression par
exemple à un endroit et bien on regarde
les bandes et ça permet souvent
d'identifier l'auteur du délit
mais ce que voudrait faire et pécresse
c'est autre chose c'est utiliser
l'intelligence artificielle c'est à dire
en fait que des terroristes présumés
des gens qui sont fichés soient reconnus
automatiquement par les caméras parce
que l'ordinateur l'intelligence
artificielle a dans son camp sont dans
sa mémoire
le profil de ces gens afin de pouvoir
identifier tout de suite ces personnes
quand elles arrivent dans le dans le
réseau ça existe déjà dans les aéroports
des valérie pécresse qui voudraient le
faire aussi pour le réseau de transports
en commun d'île de france mais pour
l'instant la loi ne le permet pas et
vous l'entendiez la présidente de la
région ile de france voudrait un débat
national est bien le débat national
il commence ce soir à point de vue j
smadja est ce que c'est une bonne idée
la vidéo protection ou la
vidéosurveillance appelons le ce
dispositif comme on veut et utile c'est
même très utile quand il s'agit de
dd la police nationale a mené des
enquêtes arrivent à identifier les
auteurs d'infractions à les interpeller
aller allait déférer à la justice
donc ça veut dire que l'utilisation de
caméras et il faut qu'elle soit il faut
calculer la doctrine que l'on a sur
l'utilisation de caméras
est ce que c'est un moyen de
surveillance de la population ou est ce
que c'est un une aide à lenquête du
travail de la police nationale moi je
suis évidemment favorable à la deuxième
option une aide à lenquête au travail de
la police nationale si c'est conçu quand
même moyen de surveillance de la
population
alors effectivement là il ya une risque
d'où un risque de dérive voilà donc tout
dépend de la doctrine que l'on veut que
l'on que l'on a à l'égard de ces de ses
outils technologiques voilà donc valérie
pécresse elle elle fait cette annonce à
trois semaines du premier tour des
élections régionales
elle ne nous dit pas à quoi ça va servir
elle nous dit pas pourquoi elle veut
utiliser par exemple le système de
d'identification faciale on ne sait pas
alors dans le figaro elle explique quand
même que ce serait pour par exemple
identifier des terroristes recherchés
oui ben les jeux je comprends pas
comment on peut comme on peut identifier
un terroriste 6 alors en fait l'idée
masse est en fait un peu comme en chine
c'est pour ça que d'une façon un peu
polémique on a on a titré cette partie
de l'émission bienvenue en chine
en chine le l'intelligence artificielle
les ordinateurs qui qui
font tourner toutes ces caméras ils ont
en mémoire le les photos de ces gens et
si jamais ils passent devant une caméra
aussitôt on les reconnaît et j'imagine
qu'on prévient les autorités compris
mais ça aujourd'hui ça n'est pas
autorisé n'ont absolument rien n'est pas
autorisée il faudrait des ben voilà
c'est ce qu'elle dit est dit il faut
changer la loi
c'est un peu le sujet je remarque ce que
vous disiez parce que c'est
effectivement la sémantique est
intéressante
valérie pécresse elle dit
vidéoprotection a dit bonne vidéo
surveillance
et on comprend très bien le le sens
quelle quelle qu'elle donne à ce mot je
n'ai pas diviser le mot vidéo protection
parce que absolument et en ayant non on
en reparlera votre point de vue gabriel
cluzel d'abord le déploiement des
caméras sur le principe ça vous gêne ou
ça vous gêne pas non j'ai pas d'avis
tranché sur la question je comprends que
avant les élections régionales parce que
la sécurité est l'enjeu majeur faillite
au coeur des inquiétudes des français
pour tous les candidats c'est un peu le
le concours lépine de la mesure la plus
forte dans ce domaine
je n'essaie pas une critique il faut
résoudre le problème évidemment
néanmoins comme d'habitude il est une
aliénation de liberté forte vous
compariez avec la chine nous ne sommes
pas des chinois je pas sûr que la chine
soit soit un pays enviable donc il faut
évidemment se méfier parce que quand on
rogne sur une liberté pour un motif tout
à fait légitime est louable chacun au
fond de soi se dit oui bah moi j'ai rien
à me reprocher je suis pas un terroriste
donc finalement c'est très bien ça
concernera les autres et bien 7,7 et
cette aliénation reste et peut être être
utilisée il c'est pour ça que du reste
un grand débat doit avoir lieu d'être
utilisés pour d'autres motifs on a vu au
moment de cette crise sanitaire que ce
qui est aujourd'hui réputé presque
criminel ne l'était pas hier je ne sais
pas à porter le masque ou autre chose
donc c'est vrai qu'une fois que et
instituer une règle et qui ont apposé
une aliénation de liberté ça peut être
un pied dans la porte pour beaucoup de
choses c'est quelque chose que l'on que
l'on doit garder à l'esprit c'est
toujours le même débat c'est entre
liberté et ses clés exactement et du
reste la sémantique vous l'avez dit
c'est un peu toujours très intelligent
de voir à quel coût
on peut arriver à la tordre c'est une
protection mais c'est aussi une
surveillance a indéniablement moi
simplement je alors pardon c'est
peut-être pas exactement le sujet mais
ça me semble nécessaire
je suis frappé de voir qu'on voit dans
une société de plus en plus surveillées
et répressive au fus rabat alors que
c'est une société en même temps
extrêmement laxiste et presque
libertaire et finalement on se rend
compte que le fait de l'avoir décorseter
de d'avoir enlevé toutes nos moeurs
communes nos codes notre conception du
bien et du mal de ce qui le savoir un
peu à une conception commune de
l'opprobe et du mérite fait
qu'aujourd'hui dans ce relativisme
absolu et bien une fille née gars plus
d'autorégulation et on est obligé de
surveiller réprimer et imaginé toute une
série de solutions pour en réalité une
société dont la la la la
comment dire la colonne vertébrale est
en train de s'effondrer et je crois
qu'aujourd'hui pour l'électorat de
droite ils attendent de valérie pécresse
sans doute tout un tas de mesures
sécuritaires peut-être de cet ordre ou
pas mais aussi commander une un vrai
corpus d'idées de reconstruction de
presque deux civilisations et j'ai pas
sûr que l'éviction des conservateurs de
sa liste soit précisément un signal dans
ce sens là le problème c'est qu'à partir
du moment où dans le logiciel de qui va
repérer les visages de présumés
terroristes
vous pouvez mettre aussi d'autres
visages vous pouvez mettre les visages
de votre opposant politique locale vous
pouvez le mettre ça et donc vous pouvez
votre opposant politique locale vous
pouvez le suivre pouvait savoir où il va
qu'il fréquente à qui il rend visite
quelles sont ses déplacements et c'est
là qu'il ya un vrai risque qu'il ya un
vrai risque de dérive est d'ailleurs
dans un certain nombre de pays qui ne
sont pas des exemples de démocratie on
se sert de cet instrument pour pour
surveiller les opposants et c'est là où
il ya où il ya un vrai problème
merci beaucoup j ce n'est pas parce que
vous venez de répondre à la question de
seine sur le site du figaro qui le dit
je ne comprends pas en quoi les caméras
priverait de liberté et bien si ces
caméras sont reliées à de l'intelligence
artificielle
elles permettent effectivement un suivi
qui pourrait être un suivi généralisé de
la population
c'est ce qui se passe en chine où tous
les habitants sont identifiés et peuvent
être suivis à tout moment cette émission
est la vôtre vous le savez donc vous
nous donner votre point de vue à la fois
sur twitter sur youtube et sur le site
du figaro en même temps que vous nous
suivez en direct
jean sur youtube nous dit des policiers
serait plus judicieux car en plus cela
crée des emplois et cela rassure les
citoyens lors on nous dit c'est pas
infaillible mais c'est quand même une
méthode qui a fait ses preuves comme au
luxembourg ou singapour qui sont deux
pays parmi les plus sûrs au monde
carole nous dit que la reconnaissance
faciale si elle permet d'identifier
instantanément par exemple les
agresseurs d'une femme dans une rame de
métro déserte
moi je dis oui et puis charlie sur
twitter qui élargit un peu le débat tant
que le nombre de places en prison
n'augmentera pas et que les juges
continueront à être laxiste toutes les
technologies d'identification seront
inutiles j ce match à ce que vous pouvez
nous raconter ce qui se passe dans votre
ville je le disais vous êtes le
directeur de cabinet du maire de
nanterre quand un maire de gauche on
sait que longtemps la gauche a été
réticente devant la vidéosurveillance et
puis elle a beaucoup changé
y compris à paris d'ailleurs quand
comment ça se passe chez vous on a un en
termes nous avons un dispositif avec 55
caméras qui sont dans la bosse sur la
voie publique dans différents quartiers
on va en rajouter 10 en 2021 voilà donc
c'est vrai que la ville a évolué
les élus le maire et les élus de ont
évolué pourquoi parce que en fait ils
ont été convaincus par un élément un
seul élément c'est que ça aide à
résoudre des enquêtes
ça aide à identifier ceux qui commettent
des infractions ceux qui commettent des
actes délictueux ça s'est avéré
d'ailleurs que depuis qu'on a ces
caméras à nanterre c'est vrai qu'on a un
certain nombre de d'individus qui ont
commis d un pyromane un auteur d'une
grande violence et voilà qu'ils ont été
identifiés grâce aux caméras
et d'ailleurs nous avons fait quelque
chose de très original qui ne se fait
dans très peu de communes on nous sommes
trois communes dans les hauts-de-seine
où c'est le cas c'est que nos caméras
sont directement reliés au commissariat
de police nationale mais ça rien de la
police nationale aux listes de la police
nationale c'est à dire que la police qui
est quand même qui l en charge travail
d'arrestations des individus qui
commettent des actes délictueux et bien
elle a accès en temps réel à toutes les
images produites par par nos caméras et
donc du coup c'est une aide considérable
au travail au travail d enquête est
d'ailleurs les dix caméras par exemple
supplémentaire que nous allons installer
cette année elles sont installées en
complète collaboration avec les services
de la police nationale locaux puisqu'ils
nous disent on aimerait bien voir une
caméra là là la terre c'est vraiment
l'objectif unique de ces caméras il faut
pas dire n'importe quoi il faut pas leur
dire préparer il faut pas dire à la
population grâce à ses caméras la
délinquance va automatiquement baisser
pas le cas mais on va de baisse de la
délinquance là où vous en avez installé
alors oui mais elle elle peut se
reporter ailleurs voilà c'est ça le
risque où les gens peuvent se de plus en
plus trouver des parades dans une carie
les gens voient la voilà donc il faut
pas dire que ça va faire baisser
automatiquement la délinquance il faut
surtout pas dire que ça va empêcher le
passage à l'acte en revanche oui est-ce
que ça permet de retrouver les auteurs
et de les interpeller oui ça c'est vrai
ça augmente l'efficacité du travail
d'enquêté de la police nationale ça
c'est incontestable sur twitter nous
vous avons posé la question êtes vous
favorable à la reconnaissance faciale
dans les transports si oui à 51% donc
c'est quand même extrêmement partagées
vous pensez gabriel cluzel qu' il faut
fixer des limites à allah allah au
déploiement de mesures de sécurité il ya
quand même une très forte demande dans
ce pays je pense que si on demandait aux
français s'ils étaient d'accord ou non
de mettre en place des dispositifs
permettant d'identifier les terroristes
je dirais tous oui oui mais précisément
je prends du reste que si ces
propositions sont faites c'est parce que
elles répondent à une attente des
électeurs je pense qu'une femme vous
aviez vous citiez une de vos internautes
une femme qui prend un couloir désert
dans le rer sdi avaya une caméra elle en
sentiments protection mais encore
faut-il que ce ne soit pas la queue du
gadget sécuritaire parce que là je fais
référence à votre autre internaute qui a
tout à fait raison c'est que s'il n'y a
pas une chaîne derrière sap à des
policiers là l'intelligence artificielle
va pas aller arrêter les terroristes
c'est pas des policiers nécessaire
derrière s'il n'y a pas une chaîne
pénale suffisamment
efficace derrière et qu'il revienne au
même endroit au même moment
il se passera la même chose par ailleurs
c'est quelque chose d'un petit peu
décalé nous allez me dire que c'est
provisoire de poser cette cette affaire
des caméras au moment où tout le monde
est masquée dans l'est dans les
transports en commun mais on va dire que
c'est conjoncturel
néanmoins c'est vrai qu'il ya une forte
attente sur trois que je vous disais que
les candidats sont obligés de déployer
une imagination forte pour pour arriver
à satisfaire leur électorat
mais il faut néanmoins se méfier parce
que quand on a peur c'est un peu comme
en matière sanitaire quand on a peur on
est prêt à signer en bas de la page un
petit peu n'importe où pourvu qu'on soit
protégée est néanmoins il faut garder je
crois que c'est le rôle là aussi de nos
politiques il faut raison garder et ne
pas donner encore une fois des outils
que qui finalement seront peuvent être à
terme utilisé dans un autre contexte
pire que my accord il ya écrit liberté
égalité fraternité sur le fronton de nos
bâtiments publics je crois que c'est
important de rester attaché à cette
notion de liberté elle est la peur
quelquefois fait prendre des décisions
qui sont qui perd est en effet
extrêmement gênantes sur ce plan là ce
qui est certain c'est que par exemple
dans un quartier où vous avez un certain
nombre de problèmes de sécurité
la présence de policiers en uniforme
visible une présence régulière est dix
fois plus efficace que n'importe quelle
caméra dix fois plus efficace d'ailleurs
valérie pécresse encore elle veut
recruter 1000 agents de sécurité
supplémentaires qui seront déployés dans
les transports en commun d'ile-de-france
ce qui portera leur nombre à à 4000
c'est un sujet qui n'a rien à voir avec
celui d'aujourd'hui mais faisait
allusion qui avait accusé la des élus
conservateurs écarté par valérie
pécresse jeu de quoi de quoi parlez-vous
je connais pas ce sujet et va écouter en
ile de france un certain nombre d'élus
alors qu'ils étaient étiquetées sens
comment vous souvenez
ce qui était élu jusque là n'ont pas été
reconduit sur la liste de valérie
pécresse
je pense à carling carmantrand j'espère
que je prononce bien son nom et un
certain nombre d'autres et ils disent
alors je n'ai pas assez creusé à ce le
sujet assez pour lui pour le dire mais
ils disent néanmoins que priorité à
donner a été donnée à des candidats eux
plus ouvert du côté de la république en
marche donc moi je pense que c'est un il
n'y a pas de tabou il faut en parler
c'est vrai que ils apportaient une
coloration conservatrice et et qui de ce
fait a disparu de la liste de valérie
pécresse elle a fait un calcul
strictement électoral est là elle a
regardé les chiffres et donc l a bien vu
que l avait beaucoup plus intérêt à
essayer de s'allier par exemple avec le
modem et c'est vrai qu'il ya pas mal de
candidats modem sur ses listes que
effectivement avec les anciens
fillonniste etc
puisqu'elle considère que l'électorat on
va dire de droite traditionnel lui est
acquis voilà les elle considère que
l'état qui est donc elle préfère
mallarmé tout ça tout ça ne relève pas
de convictions profondes tout ça c'est
celle regarde les résultats des
élections fait en fonction
voilà à est en tout cas je vous annonce
dès à présent que vous retrouverez dans
le prochain figaro magazine une
interview de valérie pécresse je laisse
la dernier les derniers mots à 6 ch qui
nous dit le problème de ces mesures
n'est pas forcément le système
automatique de surveillance mais ce que
l'état peut en faire effectivement
l'intelligence artificielle elle fait ce
qu'on lui demande de faire et en
fonction d'eux
du paramétrage qui a été effectué par
les autorités
autre sujet qui n'a rien à voir encore
que on parlait de la pandémie du masque
et on va parler de la vaccination le
ministre de la santé olivier ferrand
sera ce soir l'invité du journal de 20
heures sur tf1 pour préciser la position
du gouvernement sur l'ouverture
éventuelle de la vaccination aux
adolescents donc aux enfants âgés de 12
à 16 ans alors si jamais le ministre a
pas encore complètement arrêté sa
conviction va peut-être l'aider en lui
donnant des arguments
est ce que vous êtes favorable cabri
avec rusell à vacciner les jeunes
enfants mais pardon j'ai avant de donner
la parole
je voudrais que vous entendiez un homme
qui est à fond pour c'est intéressant
parce que c'est un point de vue très
tranché c'est celui du pédiatre robert
cohen qui était lundi sur sud radio
imaginez vous la rentrée les adultes
vaccinés qui n'auront plus le droit de
kidron loi de plus porter le masque de
pouvoir se réunir en famille et cetera
et puis aux adolescents veut dire non
non vous nous continuent à porter le
masque en classe vous ne vous réunissez
puisque la maladie doit continuer à
circuler chez vous ce n'est même pas osé
imaginer vous encore un an de 2000
classes d'enseignement distance de port
de masques
qu'est ce que vous en pensez gabriel
cluzel rencontrer discuter avec lui non
moi je suis personnellement opposé à la
vaccination obligatoire des douze
saisons l'a vraiment s'il ya des jeunes
de 12 à 16 ans qui ont des comorbidités
comme on dit particulière des exactement
fort il ya un certain nombre d'indicés
d'indications c'est tout à fait naturel
cependant pour pour avoir essayé d'en
parler avec de nombreux médecins j'ai
compris qu'il y avait toujours cette
question de la balance bénéfice risque
est que autant pour les personnes âgées
qui elle était en faveur du vaccin elle
pouvait être en faveur du vaccin 1
et bien pour les pour les jeunes ce
serait les jeunes je dirais ordinaires
n'ont atteint 2 n'ayant pas de ses co
morbidités ce serait tout à fait inédit
du reste parce que ce serait une forme
de vaccinations altruistes si j'ose dire
pour protéger une autre génération mais
mais pas eux et pour eux le coc but
c'est pas grave voilà souvent ils ne
s'en rendent même pas avec des risques
en revanche potentiel moi je n'en sais
rien et là où il du reste les médecins
qui m'ont parlé n'en savez rien non plus
mais le fait est que comme tout
médicament comme tout vaccin on peut
avoir des effets secondaires à 10 20 en
matière de vaccins il ya sud la dengue
en matière de traitement je peux aussi
vous souvenez de la sphère du distilbène
c'était pas un vaccin mais néanmoins
c'était un traitement qui a été donné
pendant 20 ans entourent aux femmes pour
pour prévenir les fausses couches on
s'est rendu compte quarante ans après
que qu'il y avait des conséquences
graves pour les enfants donc c'est
qu'elle portait donc c'est vrai que
c'est pas des décisions que l'on prend à
la légère que de rendre une vaccination
biais temps évidemment si ce virus qui
est sérieux je ne renie pas la gravité
mais était la variole ou la peste noire
et keven mortalité épouvantable ces
questions-là laisser question des effets
secondaires à long terme paraît très
secondaire mais là ce n'est pas le cas
en effet pour les 12 16 ans je crois du
reste que pour un politique ce serait
quand même très très lourd personnel de
responsabilité pardon d'apporter parce
que
on pourrait elle lui reprocher cette
décision plus tard sachant qu'adp je
vais passer la parole tout de suite j'ai
aimé il ya deux points qui mérite d'être
précisée d'abord est-ce que la
vaccination va être ouverte aux 12-16
ans puisque pour l'instant ce n'est pas
encore le cas et puis est-ce qu'elle va
être obligatoire sachant qu' on peut
sans doute déjà répondre enfin penser
qu' on répondra négativement à ce
deuxième point puisque si même pour les
adultes c'est pas obligatoire on voit
pas pourquoi ça le serait pour les plus
jeunes je ne suis pas favorable à ce
qu'elle soit ouverte aux doux 16 avril
dans vous êtes d'accord avec non pas
pour des raisons médicales
parce que je ne vais pas les invincibles
de précaution qui connaît rien
simplement les et gabriel kale je suis
pas médecin je suis pas virologue
enfin je n'y connais rien donc je ne
sais tu pas pour des raisons médicales
c'est pour tout simplement parce que je
pense quoi aujourd'hui on est en train
de passer à côté et d'abandonner ce qui
avait été définie comme les objectifs
prioritaires de la campagne de
vaccination
c'est à dire que les objectifs
prioritaires s'était d'abord faire en
sorte que la population qui est la plus
vulnérable au développement de la
maladie
c'est à dire en gros on va simplifier on
va dire les plus de 60 ans la plus
vulnérable
on est en train d'accepter l'idée qu'une
grande partie de cette population ne
soit pas vaccinés et on il ya même des
gens aujourd'hui qui s'alarme de cette
situation et qui dit attention va
atteindre un plafond de verre et ce
plafond de verre va faire en sorte que
l'épidémie soit maintenue mais si ces
gens veulent pas vous brûler mallet
force et dalila ya un problème parce que
quand vous pensez qu aujourd'hui par
exemple les chiffres qui ont été publiés
par le ministère de la santé
à la date du 20 mai donc c'est très
récent vous pensez qu'il ya un tiers des
plus de 60 ans un tiers 33% 32 %
exactement des plus de 60 ans qui n'ont
reçu aucune injection
c'est énorme or c'est cela qui demain
risquent le plus d'être en service de
réanimation qui risque le plus de
développer la maladie et pour cela vous
seriez favorable à à rendre le vaccin
obligatoire seulement oui oui
personnellement je le suis pour la
population qui est disons la plus
exposée au risque de développement de la
maladie et donc d'une certaine manière
du maintien de la situation de crise et
je le suis c'est d'ailleurs l'avis qui a
été rendu très récemment par l'académie
de médecine pour toutes les
les populations qui sont en contact avec
le public
donc les personnels soignants les
enseignants enfin voilà tous les gens
qui travaillent dans des secteurs où on
est en contact avec le public
moi je crois qu'à partir du moment où on
a fait le choix de la vaccination comme
le moyen central de lutte pour mettre
fin à cette pandémie
eh bien je pense qu'il faut aller au
bout il faut aller au bout de sa logique
parce que sinon vous allez voir que on
risque de se retrouver dans une
situation de très grande tension à la
rentrée en septembre pourquoi parce que
en septembre on va se rendre compte que
finalement on a atteint on est allé au
bout des gens qui sont d'accord qui sont
volontaires pour se faire vacciner
on va constater malgré tout que le virus
continue de circuler et là on dira mais
pourquoi parce qu'on n'arrive pas à
régler le problème est bien parce que on
aura encore une bonne partie de la
population et notamment chez les plus de
50 et 60 ans qui n'auront toujours pas
été vaccinés ce qui arrive et là vous
aurez les uns contre les autres c'est à
dire un certain nombre de français
diront ah mais c'est à cause de celui
qui est pas vaccinés qu'on est encore
dans cette situation il faut faire très
attention à ça on va écouter le point de
vue des abris avec l'usl là dessus même
si on passe d d d 12 16 ans aux plus de
60 ans mais ce qui est intéressant
vous parliez des gens qu'ils étaient pas
vacillé c'est que il reste encore une
partie non négligeable des personnels de
santé où ils ne veulent pas se faire
vacciner même si le ministère est
extrêmement discret sur ce point alors
en tout cas vous êtes tous les deux
d'accord vous vous êtes défavorable à
l'ouverture en force et de la
vaccination
pas forcément pour les mêmes raisons
mais
c'est néanmoins intéressant et nos
internautes eux sont beaucoup plus
partagés puisque on vous pose la
question sur twitter et c'est presque du
moitié moitié
il ya une petite majorité 51% qui y est
favorable
nathalie est sur la même ligne que
gabriel cluzel nous ne connaissons pas
les effets secondaires sur le long terme
de ce les effets secondaires à long
terme de ce vaccin sur les enfants
donc c'est absolument non le point de
vue de nadine expérience vaccinale aura
son premier audit fin 2022 il est
imprudent d'injecter cette thérapie
génique qui a été créé en quelques mois
à des enfants et elle parle même d'un
conscience alors que martin lui n'est
pas d'accord ça qui est formidable c'est
quand vous échanger des points de vue
qui sont différents sans vaccination des
enfants aucune perspective d' immunité
collective donc mise en danger permanent
de toute la population
c'est aussi l'avis de la bi oui il faut
vacciner les 12 16 ans car ce sont les
personnes qui contamine de plus
et puis vous l'attendiez le voilà le
point de vue de bobino
les adolescents participent à la
circulation du virus donc oui il faut
vacciner le plus possible pour atteindre
l'immunité collective
vous n'êtes pas sensible à cet argument
gabriel dix ans mais c'est si les
enfants transmettent la pandémie et
comme il faut que ça s'arrête et ben
prenons les décisions non parce que je
crois que dans ce domaine
il n'y a pas de certitude cette affaire
d' immunité collective reste extrêmement
flou on se rend compte que en angleterre
où on a été vaccinée massivement
commence à parler de varien indien qui
deviendrait extrêmement envahissant donc
la démonstration n'est pas probante et
en revanche injecter un produit dont on
ne connaît pas les conséquences à long
terme je ne dis pas qu'il y en aura
forcément mais je ne dis qu'on ne les
connaît pas et bien à des enfants qui ne
court pas un risque personnel je trouve
cela extrêmement dangereux mais tout
simplement par ailleurs ge c'est vrai
que je ne vois pas non plus la logique
puisque même pour l'obligation des plus
de 60 ans si ceux qui souhaitent moi je
pense que nécessaire que ceux qui
souhaitent se faire vacciner se fassent
vacciner
actuellement il ya encore un certain
nombre de gens qui souhaitent se faire
vacciner qui n'ayant pas d'accès
internet ne l'ont pas de façon optimale
ne l'ont pas fait mais en revanche
pourquoi obliger les gens puisque les
gens vacciner eux-mêmes sont protégés
ont en tout cas si j'en crois la logique
du vaccin devraient être protégés
personnellement donc les autres ne leur
font pas courir de danger particulier
par ailleurs pour revenir sur le
personnel soignant ou même les
militaires fait un certain nombre de
publics qui vont être visés jeunes par
la vaccine pas essentielle ment par une
vaccination obligatoire
il ya une vraie réflexion à voir parce
que l aller l élémentaire niro ne dirons
rien ils seront vaccinées sans mot dire
mais les personnels soignants en général
c'est un peu plus brillants sur ces
sujets là mais c'est vrai que on cite
souvent l'exemple de l'hépatite b
on force le personnel soignant et c'est
obligatoire ou sa lite et voyait des
allées et venues je crois entre mais on
les incite fortement à se faire soigner
quand à se faire vacciner quand même à
6b ils se protègent eux-mêmes
donc c'est je crois qu'ils font déjà
montre d'une grande comment dire
grandeur d'âme où ils ont une belle
vocation en étant personnels soignants
on ne peut pas leur demander plus de
prendre des risques plus que nécessaire
ils en prennent déjà alors qu'ils sont
jeunes
au même titre que la population que le
reste de la population il me semble que
étant jeune il doit bénéficier du même
raisonnement savez je pense qu'il ya
aujourd'hui toute une partie de la
population qui ne se fait pas vacciner
non pas par doctrine ou par idéologie
mais tout simplement parce que c'est une
partie de la population qui est écarté
de tout qui est loin de tout on est face
à un phénomène moi ce que j'appelle
d'abstention vaccinale au même titre que
l'abstention électorale
c'est à dire que à partir du moment où
c'est une injuste qui vient des
institutions et tous il ya toute une
partie de la population qui se considère
comme en dehors de ça je vais vous
raconter une expérience qu'on fait à
nanterre c'est que depuis quelques temps
on a décidé justement de ne plus
attendre que les gens nous appellent ou
assure dr lee pour prendre rendez vous
pour se faire vacciner
on va aller voir c'est à dire qu'on
installe sur les marchés au pied des
immeubles
on installe des tables avec des gens
avec des ordinateurs qui propose des
rendez vous aux gens et bien je peux
vous dire qu'à chaque fois qu'on le fait
on a entre 100 et 200 personnes qui à
qui on donne des rendez vous pour aller
se faire vacciner alors qu'est ce qu'ils
nous disent nous disent mais c'est
compliqué on nous a tellement dit qu'il
y avait pas de vaccin qu'il fallait
attendre longtemps et c'est aujourd'hui
les ratés du démarrage de la campagne de
vaccination continue de peser sur l'état
d'esprit d'une partie de la population à
l'égard de cet acte et s'est absout
c'est contre ça qui le qu'il faut lutter
et moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi le
gouvernement
on a l'impression qu'il renonce à aller
à aller chercher justement cette ce
tiers de la population des plus de 60
ans alors que ça devrait être notre
cible prioritaire mais je pense que
l'erreur a pas être a été de ne pas
mettre les médecins enfin l'erreur du
point de vue du gouvernement si sa
stratégie était de vacciner massivement
de ne pas mettre les médecins de ville
d'ailleurs du reste a été dit pour
d'autres sujets mais dans la boucle
parce que vous faites plus volontiers
confiance à votre médecin de famille que
effectivement gouvernement notamment
pour tous les ratés qui a eu au début
vous dit pas s'il m'a raconté des cracks
pour les masques pourquoi il ne sait pas
n'est pas de même pour les vaccins et je
crois que ces grands vaccinodromes ont
quelque chose d'un peu inhumain pour un
octogénaire et cela donnait la
possibilité à son médecin de famille de
vacciner aurait été sans doute plus
payant merci beaucoup à tous les deux le
dernier mot revient à nos internautes à
axel sur le site du figaro il faudrait
déjà avoir assez de vaccins pour les
adultes alors actionné objectivement ça
va mieux là les vaccins il arrive même
si on les a attendu longtemps et puis
chardons bleus qui conclut je crois
qu'il faut oser oser ouvrir la
vaccination aux douze saisons sans
obligation va écouter on en saura un peu
plus donc à 20h en écoutant olivier
ferrand merci beaucoup à tous les deux
d'avoir accepté notre invitation merci à
vous de nous avoir suivis et point de
vue revient bien sûr demain à la même
heure et au même endroit
bonsoir
[Musique]